let's talk sex sure so um
you've said something like about this
before about men should not wait too
long to have sex i think it's like
should uh uh specifically iron rule of
tomosi number three yes iron rule number
three um should men wait more than three
dates
for sex this is something you have
strong opinions well okay so uh
it the the way the rule goes is this
sorry this is this is the most
contentious of all of them that's why
we're starting it off right now of
course you're gonna throw this one out
there first um uh any woman that makes
you wait for sex the sex is never worth
the wait um or by her actions uh implies
that she is making you wait for sex the
sex is never worth the wait and let me
explain why that is because most people
are gonna say well what are they
supposed to do you just get with some
ratchet ass girl and then so who's easy
no that's not what that means
it's meant to determine genuine desire
on the part of that woman that's and uh
and i know you're familiar with the
three strikes rule we've already
i've familiarized that and did some
googling yes so um so when i when i when
i talk about um
anytime a woman makes you wait for sex
that is uh a a
a woman making rules for you as opposed
to breaking rules for you and there's a
big difference okay in let's say desire
levels or genuine desire levels when it
comes to that so it's not necessarily
about like oh just get with you know
just go bang anything on two legs it is
there is something usually that is
mitigating genuine desire
when that comes up
so
i got your response on this we're going
to come back to you because it's going
to go like one minute
exactly but we're coming back
um
should a woman make a man wait more than
three dates for sex i think there's no
magic magic number i think
first off
my big theory about dating is don't go
on random dates with random dudes with
people who you just think you're hot and
they're inviting you on a date and then
you're trying to decide whether or not
you actually like them so my whole
approach to dating is that you should go
on a date that you already do find
physically attractive and you do want to
sleep with him and then you can based on
your connection and what you
feel on that date then you should sleep
with that person is it one three five
five months like that's everybody's
personal decision i think if you wait
three four five dates doesn't really
change
what's going to happen next of course
don't sleep with every guy that you find
physically attractive or you kind of
like hit it off with
but
waiting or not waiting for sex i feel
like that's
this is
outdated
think way of thinking that oh three
dates and then okay if you don't sleep
on the third day then you're out so
you're saying that you should do your
vetting process up front yeah ask the
questions kind of get to know them
before you're on the date then you've
already kind of
established what the person stands for
what they understand what you stand for
and then whether it's one dates three
dates 10 dates you've already done the
vetting yeah because it's that's what i
was saying before about high standards
and high like experiences or whatever i
said before
it's like if you're just if you don't
value yourself you don't value your time
you're gonna go on a date with or any
guy who invites you like do you think
that i have time to go on a date with
every guy i mean i'm in a relationship
now but like do you think i have time to
go on a date with every guy who thinks
that i'm hot no but why would i do that
like why would i and then on that date i
decide whether or not like no just focus
on yourself do like make yours make sure
that you are the best version of
yourself and then you're gonna attract
those type of
men
and then when you go on a date number
one you can sleep on the first date if
you really want to like you
i don't think you're okay with that yeah
first date we hit it off
snl if you feel physically attracted to
them you feel comfortable and you kind
of know them from before like don't just
sleep with any random guy because he can
put on a show
just like like
do your research before and that's also
when i have my my followers asking me
about online dating they're like well
the first date coffee
that's a whole big
strategy that i have coffee and walk
dates are not acceptable first date
options coffee and walk dates are not
acceptable why is that oh that's you
didn't do
i don't know all the answers
no that that was my first and like the
most viral video that i said i'm explain
why why is that um
so the video went like this i do not
accept a coffee or a walk as a possible
date option neither should you first of
all i'm not a dog that needs to be
walked second i have an espresso machine
at home works fabulous
and in that video i went on and on
saying how a guy needs to pick me up and
he needs to take me to a restaurant and
he needs to
like i'm going to study you a bit like
obviously that whole video was very
dramatic and i was very like
you know looking cute and giving like
orders
but i really truly think that if a guy
is not willing to
organize organize
an experience
take me out
pay for the dinner
why would i go
like
you you don't have to do all of that but
if you are not ready to do all of that
for me we're just not a good match
because i need a guy who's willing to
put in the work and who's willing to
like show me who he is and kind of
impress me in a certain way and i
understand that's not for everyone
[Music]
you